today's draft what we would miss most if
there is no college football on the fall
uh schedule this year chris you've got
the trivia question for me what do you
have all right there johnny west
virginia you ready for this mr
mountaineer all right
1993 west virginia lost one football
game in 1993.
what team did they lose to it was in
their bowl game 19 yeah oh it's florida
uh florida i shouldn't have said that
might have not got it if i didn't say
the vote no i would have remembered i
would remember because here's the
lasting image the lasting image of that
game
is uh darren studstill who split time
with jake kelchener quarterback that
year he got hit on one play and he
walked up to the line of scrimmage and
his helmet was completely twisted
sideways and uh i'll never forget that
image and that was the moment that i
knew
that that the national championship was
not going to be realized by the west
virginia mountains
88 against notre dame yeah or in 2007
when the mountaineers were a 28 and a
half point lead uh a favorite all they
had to do was beat pitt and they lost
and uh you know that's that that's a
shame it seems it seems a common theme
with the teams you root for vikings them
i don't know with me yeah it's you
unfortunately all right uh so i get the
first pick in this one there are several
to choose from and uh let's see what we
have here um
and speaking of the topic that we just
discussed the the one thing that i will
miss more than anything else and this is
going to happen even if they play the
games because there's not going to be
the crowd there those awesome indelible
shots
of the depressed fan just you know right
when whenever that thing goes wrong and
they find that person in the stands that
often is me with just that look of
despair as his or her favorite team has
gone down in flames that that is one
thing that for whatever reason in the
nfl we don't see that but there's
something about college football where
that that that just dejection is so
unique and those images every year there
are like three or four of them that we
never forget
dr doom the killer of fun is back mike
floria have you ever seen debbie downers
all the damn things to talk about you go
negative nancy right off the bat we're
gonna talk about the band dotting the
eye wait come on go ahead johnny
positive what do you got i do like the
band
later in the draft how dare you say that
about the dotting of the eye okay all
right uh i mean right off new year's day
is the first thing i'm thinking of you
know we have no college football the new
years the holidays there it's a great
time of year i mean it's awesome you sit
there it just doesn't matter what night
of the week there's a ball game on and
of course i love the big bowl games and
the pageantry of the rose bowl and all
of that type of stuff to me that will
hurt my heart so you know i want to say
like holiday football even i almost want
to even include thanksgiving weekend in
there you know i i feel like that's part
of being an american
is like you know sitting at home and i'm
gonna eat some turkey and mashed
potatoes and let's watch a college
football game this is awesome and uh
that will hurt me on new year's
christmas whatever if there's no college
football
well and and look i i disagree with that
because the bcs
final four that's really taken away from
the bowl games like that's the focal
point the two semifinalists it is the
final and and you never know like when's
the when do they get when's the you know
when's this game on when's that game on
it's not like it used to be where it was
all hell breaks loose on january 1. so i
i'm going to be more specific and this
is a positive thing
i will miss the ohio state michigan game
and every year i find a way whenever
that game happens to engineer my travel
schedule so i can i can be somewhere to
watch that game either i get to
connecticut early
or i leave here late so i can watch that
game there is something about that game
yes there is every if there's only one
college football game i watch in a year
it's ohio state michigan and uh i i will
sorely miss that if it doesn't happen
and it looks like that one's not going
to happen because big ten among all the
conferences is teetering closest to the
edge of pulling the plug yeah well we
saw harbaugh and um you know ryan day be
a little vocal on twitter yesterday so
at least there seemed like they're
they're fighting back um
i i hear i mean didn't you make fun of
like rivalry games right as i was about
to make my first pick and then you pick
a rivalry game you didn't you make fun
of that i mean yeah yeah you're
unbelievable
and you stole my damn pick because i was
gonna have more fun with that you know i
was gonna have more fun with it and go
you know the annual jim harbaugh losing
to ohio state game
but i am with you i love that game the
rival reason i thought i i thought i was
the one who holds a grudge i mean you
have like one grudge yeah you're gonna
take it beyond the great taking it to
the grave love john
tell your dad i said hi all right what's
your next pick um all right uh
you know first quarterback
off-the-board talk you know is it trevor
lawrence is it justin fields is it
justin fields is it trevor lawrence no
i'm i i love that crap i was so excited
this year because clemson was supposed
to go to notre dame and play and of
course yes i i've been fortunate to
cover the notre dame games and be on the
sideline and see some of these great
players and man i mean clemson you know
trevor lawrence the the opportunity for
myself to just watch him as a fan but
you know the fact that i might have been
able to get to see him in person and we
won't get to see the on field you know
debate take place as feels better as
lawrence better as lawrence better than
he was his first two years he set a very
high bar i i will miss that certainly
this year if there's no college football
yeah
that one isn't done yet though i know oh
state michigan far closer to being off
the board in clemson notre dame acc
seems to be intent on trying to give it
a go all right i got a lot i can choose
from here i'm gonna go with
that crazy wide-angle field goal shot
that you don't see in the nfl with the
wide hash mark you know and the closer
you get it's like how in the hell are
they angling that thing through but just
that pre-snap look where the the t
not the t they don't use a t anymore but
where the holder is set up so far wide
that's college football yeah right
that's so that is unique to college
football yeah they do it in high school
too but you never see tv shots like that
that is a college football experience
that i will miss because i'm always
impressed at the different angles that
you have to work to get that football
through the uprights the closer you are
to the goal line and the the sharper you
are to that that that uh spot that the
ball has got to get through yeah uh yeah
okay i'll i'll take that i don't know if
i love that one okay you know i mean
that's all right then make your next
pick good okay um
man there's so many good ones here i'm a
little i'm a little stuck in and what to
do here and i've lost my train of
thought about where but i'm gonna go i
don't give a damn what you say
i'm gonna go with where my heart is
and i love the freaking bands i don't
care
the dotting of the eye when i was at
notre dame and the the first university
marching band comes out i get chills
every time and any time i turn on the
college football game and i hear
you know
uh the fighting irish song or hail to
the victors you know rocky top tennessee
whatever it may be i i to me it gets my
blood boiling it really does it gets me
wanting to play football i mean
come on i mean that's just as good as to
me i mean it's as good as it gets so i
will miss that that's a big part of
college football to me the pageantry and
all that's involved with the band the
school the cheerleaders all of it
and that's one thing that no matter how
hard the nfl tries and i wonder how hard
they really even do try it can't capture
that no that is unique to college
football and look here's the problem
even if they play just like the
depressed fan right the flip side to
your thrill from the from the fight song
it's not going to be there no it's not
going to happen there's not going to be
anybody there for the most part or if it
is it's going to be a small crowd it's
not going to be nearly the same
experience that it is so hopefully they
can get this worked out
primarily they need to make a decision
and if they have to acknowledge they
waited too long to get everything in
place and they just can't do it then
just do it do it so others can make
their plans like the nfl what is the nfl
going to do i want those saturday games
if we're not going to have college
football but hopefully they'll get
something figured out and it'll be
something more than just well we'll just
fly by the seat of our pants and hope
that it works we'll take a break more
pft live coming right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports